Nintendo switch releases March 3rd wait
really yeah what nice I don't know I I
didn't like double check what we could
talk about so I'm just gonna not talk
about stuff just ask questions and I
will okay answer appropriately
okay so breath of the wilds on is about
to release uh no bro game we're talk
about open-world games before yes my
firming elements will be be made by
Nintendo yes in Japan yes it'll be on
the Nintendo switch yes and the Wii U
and the Wii U don't forget about that
Wii U is Zelda's Nintendo's previous
console yes this has gone on we listen
and we want to talk about whether
horizon zero dawn because it was so
surprising as an overall game will hold
you over until breath of the wild comes
out if not even compete with it in terms
of an open-world game right because
breath a while for what we've seen is
the closest izella hasn't got back to
that first zelda which is completely
open just more like emphasizing
exploration but obviously to like the
hundredth degree in this case on the
Nintendo subjects just but just times
100 take a verse sell that x unders
that's what you get that 400 degree and
x 100 are very different I know I don't
want to talk about exponents right now I
just want to talk about whether horizon
zero dawn will hold you over until
breath awhile comes out in terms of
being an open-world guy so based on my
previous experience playing Zelda at
events right I'll get three and stuff
I'm trying to contextualize where I'm
presenting this in her fruit okay I can
walk off set it's cool don't denied so
yes all the things you said were true
like having bucket embargoes uh-huh all
right all right all right so having
played a little bit of breath of the
wild in the past and then jumping into
horizon yes I immediately had that
feeling of crap am i spoiling breath of
the wild for myself by playing this game
right open world survival is a thing bow
and arrow is you know like what you use
most of the time and that was some of
the source of some of the best footage
of breath of the wilds like the slow-mo
bow shot like damn that's in horizon
right well uh after going through
horizon I can certainly say that what I
expect from Zelda horizon gave me
something different there are certain
parallels to Beach
I think you can play both games and not
get burnt out I mean time will tell but
but certainly horizon is its own beast
but it definitely has that like if you
need like a taste of Zelda if you can't
get it right away but you have a ps4
encourage you to try horizon because it
offers similar things mechanically it
seems like there's much more from what I
know breath a while it seems like there
is much more room for emergent
situations like things happening that
you might not initially even consider
because I know that happens in horizon a
little bit but it seems like he's Elda
you can like from what we saw you can
snowboard down the slope on that thing
you can jump off and paraglide those are
mechanical layers right but that I'm
using emergent I can go in terms of like
not knowing that if you're in a
thunderstorm this okay this is like a
metal suit is gonna shock you I don't
see as many like um you know unfactored
situations happening that might happen
in breathitt wild in horizon zero dawn
because I've been playing like four or
five hours of this and it seems a little
more predictable than Zelda not a bad
way it just seems more condensed Zelda
seems like they're way more overlapping
mechanics I mean in a way you could say
because yes based on all the footage
coming out of like previous events one
of the things people were talking about
was did you see this thing a breath of
the wild what you can do that no did you
see this thing oh my god like everybody
did something different right that was
the story there and so horizon is in
that context a simpler game Zelda
certainly will have a lot of surprises
based on what we've seen up to this
point like it seems to indicate that
like you're gonna have to learn things
on the fly especially the beginning of
horizon is a lot more linear yeah when
you get a little bit of time to do side
questing and stuff but when we like at
e3 when everybody was playing demos of
Zelda it was like I went to a mountain
what there was a mountain oh yeah and I
didn't have clothes on so I froze like a
remake it yeah
like wait you didn't have clothes on
like so yeah in that sense I think what
we've been exposed to so far has been a
lot less linear than maybe what your
initial like what you know about horizon
if you haven't seen anything but like
previews it's it's less linear than what
you've seen from that yeah Josh Shaw and
twitch as saying that they're gonna be
different because one's Japanese the
other is Western is way right reductive
Josh well is horizon horizons western
style there's not
Western oh yeah from am sorry I mean
yeah I think you can look at maybe just
that that quintessential Nintendo charm
yeah and see how no game can ever really
replicate that as well as a Nintendo
game link is like such a dork and I love
that about him Mikey docking heroes good
like when you yeah but it's different
couple did I think Marian I shouldn't oh
um when like when he cooks he's humming
and stuff and it's just it's a very
different a character perspective I
guess if that makes sense like it like
horizon is much more like there's some
serious [ __ ] going off yeah
just for the record I gave both of them
the dollars they've put in there okay
you a dollar when we leave yeah for the
recognize us for the record don't you do
me on camera but I'm that supposin of
the camera that's not relevant
look I have a dollar I have a dollar
just it's not say Janet op condescending
to me no I'm a patron no those aren't
the opposite anyway um understanding a
patronizing er not the same they're not
the same but they're not they're pretty
opposite no they're not one is putting
someone down one is like try to make
someone else feel better by putting no I
don't have opposites um no you stat you
forfeited the words you forfeited
editorship so you don't get to tell me
what words mean Oh more video - you get
the Train anyway uh yeah or like what
we're seeing here right now just bring
it back like the moving the environment
versus in horizon there's much more you
know using the environment to do things
for you like you don't use the
environment the same way so you're
harvesting things from the environment
but like what I've seen from breath of
the while but I play - breath of the
wild is very much like finding clever
ways to interact with the environment
and that makes sense yeah like how do I
chop down a tree without an axe well I
can figure it out maybe yeah yeah it's
weird because breath the wilds world is
gorgeous and doesn't initially seem
dangerous but from what I've actually
played it is and survivals a big part of
it whereas horizon seems very dangerous
but I less dangerous yeah yeah it's so
dangerous I mean there's right half
animal to fight but I haven't had too
much trouble yet the game is very
generous in terms of being like you can
just pick up plants and keep me in your
pocket and when you need to need to
munch some for health do it whatever
like you can make an assertion yeah
working CalPERS you can heal yourself
pretty readily in a horizon yeah i would
be remissed if i did not get to some of
the Twitter questions we had earlier
this week about horizon women's um mist
isn't that's not remember miss remiss
what did I say
mist I'm sorry I'm just okay let's not
do this grammar thing you don't need
that okay page three glamour babes P
really is Mac is not Mac he Dennis he's
dead so dead as hell yeah they're
talking it's always sunny if you don't
have the invention pastry glamour babe
from Twitter was saying how long is the
game nerds are there any side missions
quest to do yeah there are side missions
a quest for sure yeah I mean I spend
about 60 hours 82 percent completion
rating and I didn't focus on side quests
that often yeah um Daniel Moss said
thoughts on the best game developers
sony has exclusives with all of them
nothing is true got a few there are more
quote unquote best game developers out
there yes
am I going to be able to hunt animals or
just machines that's about horizon which
I'm sure you also hunt animals and they
are a source of the sort of natural
resources like bones and hides that you
use to create pouches and you also use
them for a few other things so meat can
be used for health potions and stuff
like that okay man
yeah there's like there different kinds
of meat there's like bony meat and fatty
meat patty me rish meat right which is
how is that different from fatty meat I
don't know
patty is fatty rich is uh rich connotes
fat Richard who Richard Hoggart meat oh
yeah let me think for let us know what
you think will horizon zero dawn hold
you over until the breath of the wild
comes out let us know next week once you
play we'll circle back to it
we'll be on Twitter obviously Pete Brown
cally plague and magma Hardy let us know
what you think of horizon once you play
it next week or if you've already played
it I don't know depending on what your
profession is and let us know you think
about it and yeah
[Music]